Susan Daniels: Welcome back everyone, this is still the morning on day two, and this is the beginning of the third component for the morning session, we are talking about work breakdown structures and we are coming to the end of scope management and we will get him to schedule management for this session.
Susan Daniels: So lots of good things going on in the chat appreciate you guys using that time during the break to do peer to peer conversations.
Susan Daniels: I do see there's a link out there for the recordings the recordings are shipped that link should not be shared it's only for if you've missed a component.
Susan Daniels: For the recordings you ask the mentors and approvals provide on a case by case basis on to view the videos all videos will not be made.
Susan Daniels: available to all participants, it is on a case by case basis that's because PM is PM is very stringent now regarding on live participation for.
Susan Daniels: Their live boot camps that you'd be fully engaged on during the live boot camps and not miss more than 15 minutes of anyone session, but if something should occur, and you are disrupted, you do have the opportunity to go back and see what you may have missed okay.
Susan Daniels: But otherwise I do want to thank you all for slow in the role on the chat it is really I think improved the quality of this this experience for many of us now that we can have a dialogue and engage.
Susan Daniels: I see something.
Susan Daniels: So here we go let's pick up with the concept of you've built you've collected the requirements you've organized it into work breakdown structure.
Susan Daniels: you've sent out all of your work breakdown dictionary survey documents right lots of great questions that you need to build the rest of your project plan.
Susan Daniels: All this has come back and now you're building your wps right and it's got a structure, it can be look like this, or it can look like an outline view it's fine, it can be in just a standard outline within denting.
Susan Daniels: With there's some key concepts on this slide that I want to make sure we touch on before we jump into schedule management.
Susan Daniels: Control packages basically have something that have control packages are literally placeholders for where you're going to start to control the schedule and the budget Okay, this is where you went to track, so let me give you an example.
Susan Daniels: let's say that you have organized your project by the division that's going to be doing the work.
Susan Daniels: Because I think a lot of people can relate to that, regardless of the industry that they're in, and you know from the customer service department that you've got you they've got to give you what the.
Susan Daniels: Now let's get and start with marketing so from the marketing department of your new product that you're that you're helping to launch in the company.
Susan Daniels: They have to have the the marketing collateral for the website for the for the for their radio spots and for any print ads right, so you know you've got to have those marketing deliverables.
Susan Daniels: You know from sales you've got to have the contracts in place you've got to have the the ability to receive money.
Susan Daniels: setup from finance, you have to have the accounts organized to be able to post the month that the receivables right.
Susan Daniels: And you know from a customer service that they have to now be familiar they've got to have training organized for them on the new product they've got to be able to have frequently asked questions and answers developed so you've got some deliverables that you know.
Susan Daniels: Your control account is where you set at what level of detail, as you break down the work you want to start reporting on right.
Susan Daniels: Do I have a part of the company that they've been doing this they're pros nothing's this is this isn't going to be difficult for them, so you can manage them at the high level of just a service organization right.
Susan Daniels: You can just monitor the budget and their performance schedule there on time for service.
Susan Daniels: Or is it a part of the company that is new got some new leadership, this is innovation for them, so you want to monitor and control at a much lower level of detail.
Susan Daniels: you're going to track lower and deeper into the work breakdown, not just at the department level or not just at the type of work, but right down to like much deeper into the work.
Susan Daniels: Then you might want to set the control accounts deeper in your work breakdown structure.
Susan Daniels: But it's where you're tracking schedule and time and, of course, the scope is the word package itself, how is it progressing according to plan.
Susan Daniels: Now to keep your work, your work breakdown structure well organized you might want to insert some things, called planner okay planning packages.
Susan Daniels: Which are a little more than placeholder lines on an outline or a box on your structure that looks like what you see on screen.
Susan Daniels: That just simply says what the name of it is is kind of that help organize you might have sales marketing customer service and then below that you might have.
Susan Daniels: The type of work that you need training on customer service REP scripts right, you might, and then there might be different scripts that have to be done in different types of trainings that would fall underneath it.
Susan Daniels: But that training and scripts would just be a placeholder or a planning package.
Susan Daniels: that's what those are there's kind of for naming and organizing your your entire document.
Susan Daniels: Two things I do want you to on to be able to know for sure is that the lowest level of your work breakdown structure is called a work package.
Susan Daniels: Everything above, it is just kind of helping to organize where it's coming from and who's doing it, what kind of work, it is.
Susan Daniels: The deliverables are the bottom love, but the bottom row okay everything above it again, is where it's coming from and who you know what type of work, it is.
Susan Daniels: And then you name, the thing The second thing you need to know about or packages for sure is that we're packages are nouns their things they are a result.
Susan Daniels: When we get into scheduling which is next we break down these work packages or decompose them even further and they go into activities Okay, but in a web is the lowest level the Web s is a work package.
Susan Daniels: hey.
Susan Daniels: that's pretty common question.
Susan Daniels: So Oh, here it here's an important part to this number is all over this slide right and they're called identifiers, these are called your code of accounts.
Susan Daniels: And the reason you start putting numbers on your work packages is you want to know where you're being charged from when you start getting billed okay your project starts getting things charge to it.
Susan Daniels: You want them to have an identifier, so that you can readily go to your work breakdown package and go oh OK, so this charge ties to 1.22 which is this work package cool.
Susan Daniels: that's a realistic it's within what I expected Okay, but if you start seeing things being charged to your project.
Susan Daniels: Without the identifier it shouldn't happen, you should have a better relationship with accounts.
Susan Daniels: payable right an internal and finance nothing gets posted to your your project without having these identifiers.
Susan Daniels: Again, another sign of a P amp T versus someone out there winging it is P MPs know to put these safeguards up so that people can't just charge hours off to your off to your project without having an identifier right that the code of account.
Susan Daniels: So it says it's a it's a technique that we use to keep people from charging indirectly to us, believe me, this happens in very large corporations, particularly in on.
Susan Daniels: Why employees that have to costs allocate they have to charge their hours off to somewhere every day right.
Susan Daniels: And if they find that there's a project that you know doesn't have any constraints on it, then they can just charge hours off to it.
Susan Daniels: And, and these happen to know the secret code right having to know what the work package code, specifically that they want to build to.
Susan Daniels: kind of keeps them from picking your project as a place to dump their hours just kind of a lessons learned there okay.
Susan Daniels: So how do we, how do you set up these code of accounts in these identifiers anything that's logical Okay, you can basically start.
Susan Daniels: At the top row and just start naming across right, this is 12345 and then you just start naming down from there it's just something that's logical okay generally follows an outline structure.
Susan Daniels: Okay um give me a second we've got another one of these coming up for effective okay this isn't the way.
Susan Daniels: Give me a moment.
Susan Daniels: Go here.
For effective.
Susan Daniels: Effective recording running there we go.
Susan Daniels: playlist.
Susan Daniels: nice thing is, you can organize your playlist by any topic that you want.
Susan Daniels: breakdowns.
Susan Daniels: You can tackle any major job in your personal or work life by breaking it down into manageable and achievable steps.
Susan Daniels: In the context of project management, the work breakdown structure or wps is a means to do just that.
Susan Daniels: It gives you control of a project by breaking work down into manageable units to create a wps you use a process of decomposition.
Susan Daniels: During decomposition you subdivide the elements of your project into progressively smaller components, starting with the project name and refining each level of decomposition until you are able to identify the smallest units of work that must be done.
Susan Daniels: The wps is one of your best friends when it comes to planning and then managing a project, it has some pretty important roles.
Susan Daniels: First of all, it helps you define project TEAM members responsibilities, it does this by breaking down project deliverables into work packages.
Susan Daniels: Each of which is small enough to assign to particular project TEAM members, this makes it possible to allocate clear responsibilities for each required unit of work.
Take the example of a water supply project, one of the deliverables is a pumping station.
The task of constructing the pumping station is divided into three sub tasks building construction pump installation and electrical installation.
The electrical installation for the pumping station requires the team to set up the utility electrical supply and a team to install a backup generator the project manager uses the wps to review the work required and determine who to assign to perform the tasks.
Susan Daniels: The project manager then assembles two teams, with the necessary skills draws up a description of the tasks, the members of the team must perform and informs the foreperson of the team's responsibilities.
Susan Daniels: Another role that the wps plays is in allowing better control of the project.
Susan Daniels: Staying with our example when the project manager for the water supply project finds that one of the electricians assigned to install the backup generator is going to be absent for eight weeks, he checks the wps.
Susan Daniels: He wants to assess how this affects the work package for installing the backup generator to avoid delays, he hires another electrician.
Susan Daniels: This will add to the cost of the project by running this changing costs up through the wps he is able to get an idea of the impact this could have on the project as a whole.
Susan Daniels: The project manager uses the wps to monitor and control the project budget, so if the addition of another electrician to the project costs $3,000.
Susan Daniels: He will be able to use the wps to see the areas of the project that would be impacted by this change and judge the implications for the project as a whole.
Using the wps the project manager can ensure that no extra cost is overlooked, he can see how budgetary changes will impact the project and so can quickly take steps to deal with problems.
by breaking work down into manageable units, the wps also facilitates accurate progress reports and can give stakeholders, a context for interpreting reported progress, you can include the latest version of the wps in regular status reports for key stakeholders.
Susan Daniels: A double UBS also helps you with scheduling if you're using the wps when creating the schedule, you know for sure that you've included all the work needed to complete the project.
Susan Daniels: A good way to observe its effectiveness is to turn the Web s 90 degrees counterclockwise.
Susan Daniels: You will notice that the elements required to complete a project from the most basic activities to the final objective are laid out from left to right.
Susan Daniels: This provides you with a start to finish workflow for your project, the wps also facilitates budget creation.
Susan Daniels: The costs associated with each decomposed element of a wps will be the some of the costs of all of the elements underneath it.
Susan Daniels: If you've identified all the work at each level, you can be certain that the costs associated with each identified area will be budgeted for.
Susan Daniels: If you forget something your budget may be deficient.
Susan Daniels: The project manager for the water supply project can determine what the construction phase will cost simply by adding all costs from the lower levels of the double ups that feed into this phase.
Susan Daniels: You could use this method to gauge costs that any level of the double UBS setting control accounts to monitor important cost components of the project.
Susan Daniels: One final point to bear in mind about the wps is that it should identify work products or deliverables the results of effort, rather than the effort itself.
Susan Daniels: A good way to do this is to make sure you list all components as nouns instead of verbs This is because the names in the wps tell you what should be achieved not how it should be achieved.
Susan Daniels: So, in summary, the double UBS has four main purposes, it enables you to assign responsibility to TEAM members and control a project as it progresses, it also enables you to create an accurate project schedule and facilitates accurate cost estimates.
Susan Daniels: Hopefully that answered some of your questions by giving you a visual example of a work breakdown structure for that water project.
Susan Daniels: i'm going to reiterate that you should use only nouns in your work breakdown structure we start using verse when we start doing our schedule, which is the activities that it takes to produce each of these work packages.
Susan Daniels: I thought that Barbara walters in a really good job with that video.
Susan Daniels: So let's see if there's a couple of questions um I thought it was interesting is the arm.
Susan Daniels: Is the identifier, how you label each of the word packages in the web, how you use that in the different, let me rephrase that, how do you use the code of account identifiers in the wps is it like the contract line Item number.
Susan Daniels: If the contract line item is.
Susan Daniels: I would say, highly highly similar if we're thinking, the same thing Lee which is contracts, often itemized by line, what are the deliverables that are expected So yes, your work package might be the line item by the contract.
Susan Daniels: There can be a parallel, but that would be circumstantial because it depends on how that contract is written, but there is definitely a corollary you tracking with a concept.
Susan Daniels: um.
Susan Daniels: Do you do the wps on repeatedly you know, is it is it something that's updated throughout.
Susan Daniels: i'm typically you try to lock in the scope in our traditional waterfall plan based okay you lock in this gather all the requirements lock get those.
Susan Daniels: Requirements approved and then you've locked in your scope, so you wouldn't be doing web SS again Okay, because you've in a predictive or traditional you're one and done right, you know as you're trying to do.
Susan Daniels: And now, any changes go through formal change control and only after formal change control would you do an update to your wps.
Susan Daniels: The caveat to that is that if you choose to do an incremental approach like that big construction of a mall and once you you're only doing the wps necessarily in great detail.
Susan Daniels: For the first first phase, and then you build out in great detail there on the web so for the second phase, you know that would make sense that she was still have an overarching.
Susan Daniels: Broad wps for the whole project you just haven't gotten all the way down to the fine details are locked in the schedule and the budget.
Susan Daniels: Because you know things change in construction environments right, so you may want to apply, you know lock it in for your baseline only as you get closer to implementation.
Susan Daniels: But she was still do from the beginning, the whole plan you know what is the master plan, but then you wouldn't lock it in until you get to that increment.
Susan Daniels: Okay let's see ah, quite a few going on here hey um.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: So we are coming to the end of scope management and we're trying to create our scope baseline so.
Susan Daniels: The scope baseline if you're asked what are all the elements that are included in a scope baseline it is that project scope statement.
Susan Daniels: Which is what is used for referencing frequently by people who don't want to go into the details okay your web s which you built designed right it's it's your map on how you're going to manage the schedule in the budget, it is the foundation from which you build the rest of your documentation.
Susan Daniels: You have identification of all of your work packages your planning packages and a fistful of work breakdown dictionary responses right you've got the explanations and details for each of your web more packages, you have that corollary dictionary.
Susan Daniels: overtime on I would encourage you to add i've learned to add a signature to the bottom of the work breakdown dictionary survey okay.
Susan Daniels: Where they send you their response you dialogue about it once you've reached agreement, and maybe some editing back and forth between.
Susan Daniels: The two of you, but once you've locked on what that dictionary contains, then you have.
Susan Daniels: Now got something you can hold them accountable to and they've got something going to hold you accountable to which means, yes, they can go get the temp staff that they need or Yes, you are going to provide this sort of resource to them.
Susan Daniels: in a timely manner so it's I said, an agreement document of what is being expected by both parties.
Susan Daniels: The work breakdown dictionary is extremely important and depending on your industry.
Susan Daniels: is going to be a customized to your industry and then ultimately customized to your organization, but the slide told you some starting points of things that she should consider including as far as sections of your web s dictionary.
Susan Daniels: But when you have all of this built.
Susan Daniels: You have your scope baseline.
Susan Daniels: The guidelines are available to you out under load choice, once you get your pmi membership and you've got your.
Susan Daniels: Access key for the plp exam prep kept from pmi you use that access key to go to load choice with on pmi and once you once you get there you'll see a title and the title will have checklists and this checklist or where you see all of these guidelines that was a question earlier.
Susan Daniels: All right, wow we've got about 15 minutes to cover it concept of plan and manage schedule.
Susan Daniels: We use lots of tools in managing our our our.
Susan Daniels: and trying to develop our schedule, but we really can't build our schedule until we developed our scope and have all of our work packages, because the schedule is really just trying to lay out the work all the activities it takes to build those work packages over time.
Susan Daniels: So if you're going to jump in.
Susan Daniels: and try to build a Microsoft project Gantt chart you can't do schedule until you've done scope.
Susan Daniels: Now we'll be talking about quite a few of these over the coming minutes.
Susan Daniels: As you can see, there are a lot.
Susan Daniels: So someone really said what happened to all the inputs tools techniques, you know from the sixth edition they map them to the different tasks okay.
Susan Daniels: So we have different layouts or visual on visualizations of a schedule and it's important that you understand the difference between like a milestone schedule a Gantt chart view okay on a detailed view.
Susan Daniels: But this is showing you a Gantt chart This is just basically showing you the work over time.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: it's used to coordinate the cost and to track it's it's your tool for tracking performance.
Susan Daniels: Now, when you're looking at ways of setting up your schedule Okay, you can look at benchmarks in the industry well how long did it take them to build it or design it or do it right, how how fast, are they at this right as a starting point.
Susan Daniels: Or you can go and look at historical data from your organization itself, you can look external or you can look internal if you're just trying to get a sense of how how to lay it out and how to estimate for it.
Susan Daniels: Look there's another plan that we're developing think of another tab in your three ring binder in your schedule and in your project implementation plan, so we have a schedule management plan, and there are certain components that go into it.
Susan Daniels: But fundamentally it's going to describe.
Susan Daniels: What template are you going to use what tools are you going to use who are you going to send the schedule to.
Susan Daniels: who's going to where you're going to get your estimates from, and you can basically say you're going to get the source of your estimates will be from the accountable party for each word package, I mean the schedule management plans don't have to be very robust.
Susan Daniels: Just telling your leadership, what you're going to do and how you're going to do it to build your schedule, where you're going to store it out.
Susan Daniels: Who has access to it who's going to be able to update it how often are you going to republish your schedule right, these are some of the questions that you answer in your own schedule management plan.
Susan Daniels: and
Susan Daniels: Alright, like I do want to talk to you about X accuracy of activity duration estimates.
Susan Daniels: As opposed to tolerances okay so accuracy of estimating you want in this memo in this letter in this plan that you send up to your senior leadership for approval.
Susan Daniels: You want to negotiate with them how accurate, do you have to be hey do can I be plus or minus an hour a day a week okay in my estimates and you're going to say that that you're going to try to set what it is that you think is.
Susan Daniels: What you can achieve as far as accuracy.
Susan Daniels: They will let you know whether that's acceptable or not again that kind of gets back to the culture of the organization you're working with but there's a difference between.
Susan Daniels: In your plan saying my estimation accuracy and my performance tolerances i'll repeat that there is a difference between you're estimating accuracy.
Susan Daniels: just trying to guess here, you know i'm getting it from the the subject matter experts, the people doing the work closest to the work that's where my estimates are coming from and we're going to try to be plus or minus you know one time box.
Susan Daniels: But in my tolerance is for performance it's a different thing this is once everything starting to roll how close Am I to staying to my schedule, I want, not to be perfect, but to have a plus or minus tolerance as well.
Susan Daniels: hey the project schedule model used are you going to use.
Susan Daniels: send them just high level milestones are you going to give them detailed.
Susan Daniels: Very detailed or do they want just a with Gantt chart accuracy, for every activity listed mean you want to negotiate with them what the models should be that they get as their performance report.
Susan Daniels: This is simply says here in my plan are all the links that are applicable relative to the schedule, as in where it's being stored on and.
Susan Daniels: How to access the the tool that is being used in right now just anything that they need links to goes in this master plan.
Susan Daniels: Of course, you want to negotiate what's the unit of measure, this is pretty straightforward day our day week month quarter, how are you how are you laying out your schedule.
Susan Daniels: Rosa performance measures to be used that's really back to your tolerances okay.
Susan Daniels: um this is how you schedule management process, this is simply says how frequently, are you going to update your schedule.
Susan Daniels: And who's got authority to update it and who has access to it that that sort of thing.
Susan Daniels: and your control thresholds right for pro for performance.
Susan Daniels: There are different considerations for agile than there is in traditional pain in the agile environment, we are working off of iterations and each iteration if you're doing.
Susan Daniels: Typical scrum in is two weeks, but I have seen when i've asked people you know what are they what are they seeing in their industry, which is, this is a great time, would you please put in chat if you are working in an agile environment, what is the duration of your iterations.
and
Susan Daniels: wow weekly okay.
Susan Daniels: Lots of two weeks, but what you're seeing that that is not the absolute okay usually ranges from two to four weeks.
Susan Daniels: That has to deal with because for people that are on a four week cycle is because finance has not adapted to the agile environment and they're not willing to.
Susan Daniels: Provide performance reports and updates on a two week cycle or a three week cycle, but I am seeing that two weeks and three weeks seems to be the norm for their for their iterations.
Susan Daniels: I don't know how you're using as needed as an iteration because part of this is being able to predict how long it's going to do to clear your backlog.
Susan Daniels: And if you just make an iteration is as long as you think it's going to take then you're probably doing scrum doing agile like, but not necessarily pure agile in your in your environment.
Susan Daniels: On these are just a few checklist of things to consider when developing just trying to develop your your schedule management plan.
Susan Daniels: So your schedule is really all about building out the activities for each one of your work packages.
Susan Daniels: And you don't you don't invent this you get this from your wps dictionary is provided for you all that has to happen is to crosswalk the information off the survey document or the questionnaire into your scheduling.
Susan Daniels: scheduling tool you enter the work package, and then you either indent Okay, or you tag if it's in a mind map or whatever way you need to but you're basically tagging the activities below the word package.
Susan Daniels: So.
Susan Daniels: The lowest level in a schedule our tasks okay.
Susan Daniels: tasks and i'm.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: milestones okay activities are the lowest level right milestones are the highest level and there's two elements about a milestone that you need to know a milestone.
Susan Daniels: can be two things one it marks the end of a major body of work Okay, it might have several work packages after under it let's go back to the marketing so marketing has to do the campaign and Scott.
Susan Daniels: um what it needs to do for the Internet what it needs to do for radio and what it needs to do for print right and underneath that would be different.
Susan Daniels: tasks that it has to accomplish around write the copy identify the graphics proofread right there's different tasks that have to happen to be able to produce that aspect of the campaign.
Susan Daniels: When all three of those are done and the marketing campaign is you know developed Okay, and that would be a milestone.
Susan Daniels: milestones on Gantt charts are have zero duration, they are simply an indication of an achievement of a major body of work Okay, and so on the test, please know that milestones are of zero duration okay.
Susan Daniels: here's an example of a milestone chart.
Susan Daniels: And each one of these, this might be the marketing campaign, this might be getting the arm.
Susan Daniels: Well, I would do several things first, but I would probably try to.
Susan Daniels: Train my staff and then I would be able to launch some different things, but to mow your marking the work over time, but it's large bodies of work okay.
Susan Daniels: And milestone charts are used for upper management, they really do not want to be bothered with the details, they have so much going on in their wingspan that.
Susan Daniels: They will ask you for details if they need it, they want to be made aware of.
Susan Daniels: And to know about, but if they want to go deep they'll let you know Okay, because oftentimes they're sitting in meetings that only a tan gently relate to what they're doing and they're they're there for awareness okay.
Susan Daniels: um and they're looking for things that would adversely impact their divisions their concerns or things where they see strategic alignment so they're there for awareness.
Susan Daniels: you'll you'll get to know when they need additional detail so most communications to senior management is very high level, and then you just wait for the questions.
Susan Daniels: isn't a milestone similar to an objective or intermediate of objective in a project, you have overarching objectives of that project, so a milestone is not really achievement of an overarching objective Okay, there is a completion of a major body of work and.
Susan Daniels: What is.
Susan Daniels: What is the lowest level, a task on a schedule is usually an activity on a schedule.
Susan Daniels: um oftentimes in software they don't use the the work breakdown structure language of a work package, they use something called a task.
Susan Daniels: So in today's software you don't get to choose work package you get to choose tasks so that's what that slide was trying to say was oftentimes you have to choose that command you want to create a new task.
Susan Daniels: But when you go to have this task, and there are activities that have to happen to execute that task, the lowest level on a schedule is an activity.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: i'm not going to spend time commenting on.
Susan Daniels: It.
Susan Daniels: But most of your estimating from project activities is going to come from the people doing the work themselves right or you're going to look at what they say in their standard operating procedures of how long something should take to get it done.
Susan Daniels: um, but these are the things you take into consideration when you're estimating project activities.
Susan Daniels: What I wanted to continue on and talk about.
Susan Daniels: Is your activity dependencies.
Susan Daniels: I think we've worked in environments enough to know that there are handoffs right that you can't get started until.
Susan Daniels: Something is done until this is handed to you or oftentimes you might be the order that the team that has to get something done in time to hand off to somebody else, so we have to in our mapping in our software and in our schedules we try to indicate where those things exist.
Susan Daniels: And we have certain kinds of dependencies.
Susan Daniels: On give me a moment to look at that, but it's a middle i'm going to tell you why is important to note these the way they are.
Susan Daniels: Okay, so picture this, if you will.
Susan Daniels: you've got you've built your schedule.
Susan Daniels: And you've indicated the different kinds of dependencies we'll talk very specifically by about that whether it start to finish finish to start.
Susan Daniels: And you're in a situation where you have to compress your schedule your senior leadership walks by NGOs.
Susan Daniels: they're sweeping funding for this for all projects at the end of the quarter okay we're only going to get what we get done okay that's not good news so you've got to figure out how to compress your schedule to deliver as much value as possible Okay, by the end of the quarter.
Susan Daniels: Well, when you look at your schedule, you have this opportunity when you're compressing to try to figure out where your opportunities spaces are okay.
Susan Daniels: The place, you can you can compress is where you don't have mandatory external sort of dependencies well what would be an example of that.
Susan Daniels: Well, mandatory be something that's generally regulatory Okay, or is dependent on nature samples would be.
Susan Daniels: permits right you can't move forward to get the permits or the concrete has to dry or cure before you can move forward these are sort of mandatory dependencies hey you kind of have to put these delays in right you're dependent on something to happen.
Susan Daniels: discretionary would be something that you choose to do that way because it's logical it's the way that minimizes any risk, it is the natural sequence of things i'm going to.
Susan Daniels: Code, the screens then i'm going to write the user manual once this Greens are developed right, it makes sense not to start writing the user manual for this free screen until the screen is fully coated.
Susan Daniels: In fact it's best, not even to write the user manual until the screens are made, or at least that whole component is done.
Susan Daniels: Internal and external is pretty obvious external would be like you're on regulatory bodies your internal is really something within your organization, you can probably influence okay.
Susan Daniels: So.
Susan Daniels: What we want to what I want to show you is the different kinds of.
Susan Daniels: President relationships and this really has to do with the predecessor and successor Okay, and whether these two things are dependent on each other and what kind of relationship that is so.
Susan Daniels: This is the slide where we saw earlier someone asked about timing, with the fs in SF FF and all these different acronyms are well, this is what is referring to.
Susan Daniels: And we have a video on it about activity relationships so i'm going to go ahead and play the video, but what is trying to basically say is.
Susan Daniels: on which one has to start in which one has to finish and can they finish together or can they start together to give me a moment and I will TEE up the next video for us.
Susan Daniels: Once you've decomposed the wps into activities you'll have many activities, but no schedule, at least not yet it will be necessary to figure out which activities must be performed and in what order.
Susan Daniels: One of my favorite books about project management is called the project management handbook by fergus o'connell.
Susan Daniels: fergus says that you should run your projects, the same way you'd cook dinner, you should make sure you have all of the ingredients first and follow the recipe like a plan.
Susan Daniels: There are steps and they happen in a necessary order if you don't add certain ingredients at the right time, the outcome just won't be successful.
Susan Daniels: you'll need to sequence activities in your project to you'll identify the logical relationships between activities and also which resources are available and when, in order to develop a realistic schedule.
Susan Daniels: will also discuss leads and lags which includes purposeful overlap of activities and purposeful delays between activities.
Susan Daniels: There are four reasons that dependency relationships may exist between activities, a mandatory relationship is contractually required or inherent to the nature of the work.
Susan Daniels: it's hard logic if you're pouring a concrete sidewalk the concrete must dry or cure before you can walk on it.
Susan Daniels: or it could be your customer who says we want you to complete this task, first, then we'll inspect it and if it passes inspection will give you the okay to start the next task.
Susan Daniels: discretionary relationships are based on knowledge of best practices or desired specific sequences, they must be documented, since they can create additional unnecessary flow in the schedule.
Susan Daniels: We haven't talked about flow yet, but what we mean is that there should be a reasonable justification for performing activities in sequence.
Susan Daniels: Rather than concurrently because sequential activities take longer to accomplish on the schedule often there is soft logic behind a discretionary dependency.
Susan Daniels: For instance, let's say that you have a subject matter expert in your organization and you would like that person to be involved in two tasks.
Susan Daniels: You can't pay overtime and you don't want to burn this person out so instead of performing the activities concurrently he'll do them one, at a time.
Susan Daniels: With external dependencies perhaps there's a relationship between project activities and non project activities that are usually outside of the team's control.
Susan Daniels: For example, a few years ago, our town was trying to arrange a concert for the Community what they didn't account for was that a very popular music group was performing on the same day at another venue.
Susan Daniels: Unfortunately, that meant there was a shortage of event staff and they determined that they wouldn't be able to set up the stage and the event site until those staff members were available.
Susan Daniels: This caused them to create a dependency between the other project and there's internal dependencies are relationships that are internal to the company or to the project.
Susan Daniels: They still may be in or outside of the team's control, though, for example, perhaps your project is sharing resources from another team and your organization.
Susan Daniels: And they're still needed on that other project that they're working on, they may not be available for your project until the other project is completed.
Susan Daniels: There are four types of sequencing relationships and the first is finished just start in this type of sequencing one activity must finish before another activity can start.
Susan Daniels: In a project schedule network diagram a finished to start relationship is shown as an arrow connecting the right side of the preceding activity to the left side of the successor or subsequent activity.
Susan Daniels: The finish to start is the most common type of relationship One example is that you must finish a background check before a new hire can begin working.
Susan Daniels: This is logical, because if someone starts working and then you find out that they didn't pass their background check there could be various consequences that would have been avoidable if the dependency was built into the plan.
Susan Daniels: With the start to start sequencing relationship one activity must start before another activity can start.
Susan Daniels: In a project schedule network diagram a start to start relationship is shown as an arrow connecting the left side of the preceding activity to the left side of the subsequent activity.
Susan Daniels: The great thing about a start to start relationship is that you can perform some of the work in parallel and build efficiencies into the schedule, however.
Susan Daniels: There is a sequencing because one of these activities must start before the other can start.
Susan Daniels: For example, you can start the new hire paperwork and then start the background check maybe using a vendor both could be working through the system, at the same time.
Susan Daniels: In the finish to finish sequence one activity must finish before another activity can finish.
Susan Daniels: In a project schedule network diagram a finish to finish relationship is shown as an arrow connecting the right side of the preceding activity.
Susan Daniels: To the right side of the subsequent activity, perhaps a team member is leaving your team you select the new team Member and arrange for their training to finish before the team Member leaves the company.
Susan Daniels: In a start to finish relationship one activity must start before the other activity can finish.
Susan Daniels: In a project schedule network diagram a start to finish relationship is shown as an arrow connecting the left side of the preceding activity to the right side of the subsequent activity.
Susan Daniels: This type of dependency can be tricky so let's explore some examples, can you think of a type of job, where the employee cannot go home until the replacement arrives.
Susan Daniels: Maybe it's due to safety or security reasons, what about security guards pool lifeguards or nurses, if a shift of nurses was preparing to go home.
Susan Daniels: But the next shift couldn't arrive because of, say, a big snowstorm or a closed highway that first shift of nurses would need to stay.
Susan Daniels: This is a start to finish relationship once you've sequenced activities you'll be able to create a project scheduled network diagram.
Susan Daniels: You may already have software that does this for you, but it is helpful to know how that software works, a scheduled network diagram reads from left to right the first activity in this diagram is activity, a.
Susan Daniels: The start of activity, a is on its left side and the finish of the activity is on its right side once activity, a is finished activities H F and I can start.
Susan Daniels: So there is a finished to start relationship between activity, a and these three activities, because there are no arrows between activity H and F, or between activity F and I.
Susan Daniels: These activities don't have dependencies they can be performed at the same time we proceed through the network diagram from left to right following the project activities chronologically from beginning to end.
Susan Daniels: When one activity must be finished before the next one can start this dependency makes the activities sequential or one, at a time.
Susan Daniels: When activities don't have dependencies and can be performed at the same time, this means that they are concurrent, also known as being performed in parallel.
Susan Daniels: In the first example of sequential activities activity, a is the predecessor of activity D activity D is the successor of activity, a.
Susan Daniels: In the example of concurrent activities activities, two and three both have dependencies with activity one activity, one must finish before either activity two or three can begin.
Susan Daniels: But activities, two and three, do not have dependency relationships between them so they can be performed at the same time.
Susan Daniels: So we have a few minutes left before we break for lunch, and we have one of those opportunities, where we can really just have a nice exchange, because the chat is now under control.
Susan Daniels: And we can use the time we have together to answer some questions over the things that we've covered this morning, so i'm going to just turn, I have a chat sitting over here on this cream on the now read some questions and see if I can answer them for you in the time that we have.
Susan Daniels: Can I provide a good example of start to finish um that's the most common Okay, the start to finish his arm I can't basically I can't start to icing the cake until the cake is done baking and cooled until the cake is cooled So this has to finish as to finish cooling before I can start.
Susan Daniels: In this start to finish activity has the first shift of nurses and activity be has the second show, but the diagram shut off.
Susan Daniels: The APP the nurses, one is the finished to start Okay, which basically says i'm these have to start the new nurse has to arrive before they the existing nurse can finish her her arm her shift so that would be the.
Susan Daniels: i'm sorry.
Susan Daniels: This is the nurses example, this is the.
Susan Daniels: baking the cake, I might have labeled them wrong, but this is the nurses one, this is the i'm baking the cake.
Susan Daniels: Okay, can you promote it okay.
Susan Daniels: let's see.
Susan Daniels: yeah I thought I did have a mixed up i'm sorry so finished to start this has to finish before this can start this has to start the new person has to on this has to start before this can finish.
Susan Daniels: Other questions we covered on this is kind of look back over we did the scope management plan all the work breakdown structure, there was a good question is, as already scroll by, but it was you know it seems like.
Susan Daniels: A lot of these these dependence, a lot of the plans that we're going to be doing, are all kind of dependent on one thing, and it is fundamentally getting to your work breakdown structure.
Susan Daniels: From your work breakdown structure you're going to build your schedule from your work breakdown schedule of from your work breakdown structure.
Susan Daniels: you're going to build on your budget as well you're going to build from that you'll learn where you're going to need to have procurement.
Susan Daniels: hey there is just that is the foundation of the rest of your plan and to get to the real details you use your your arm wps dictionary survey document let's see um.
Susan Daniels: A good way to think of start to finish, is security.
Right.
Susan Daniels: start to finish security guards versus all of those right i'm surprised, they don't have any more questions um there are 800 of you off so i'm thinking, there are some questions lurking back there, do you want to move a couple of them forward.
Susan Daniels: Whether it has to do with the scope tolerances on opus ethos.
Susan Daniels: Focus groups benchmarking paying.
Susan Daniels: Different types of group decision making tools okay.
Susan Daniels: Can you can you review the difference between task and activity, or are they synonymous Okay, this is a very Gray area Okay, so let me give you the pmi terminology because it's about the pmi test right the pmi terminology is work package, the lowest level and a wps.
Susan Daniels: activity is the lowest level in a schedule that's pmi language, where task comes in, is it many software's today.
Susan Daniels: Use task as a work package, something that is do that is deliverable, it is not a term that is used in the the pmi lexicon Okay, though, I hope that helps so when you're asked the answering test questions you're looking for work packages and activities tasks will not be an answer.
Susan Daniels: Okay let's just leave it to questions on tips images, but tips to manage a sponsor when they decide to add work outside the scope of a project.
Susan Daniels: You tell them that you arm he, this is a sponsor right.
Susan Daniels: This is this person got the money to get the project done if you mean a stakeholder who wants to add extra work that's a different thing, but if a sponsor wants to add additional work.
Susan Daniels: They generally have the money to make it happen, it still has to go through formal change control and we'll talk about that that's a whole lecture topic.
Susan Daniels: Formal change control, but they to and have to go through formal change control and as a project manager, one of the things you're responsible for identifying is how is project change managed in your organization.
Susan Daniels: And I will share with you from my years of consulting and an array of organizations winging it is pretty much the way they do, and they call a meeting decide and may change, not a lot of formality, not a lot of structure your project can get jerked around a lot.
Susan Daniels: If you want to really do high end project management, you want to from the beginning, identify who's on your change Control Board.
Susan Daniels: What is the application process how often does your change Control Board meet all right, and how does one apply for a formal change control.
Susan Daniels: And even a sponsor unless they're the only sponsor the most time there's a couple of people that come together to get the money for the project.
Susan Daniels: That so there has to be agreement by the sponsors, but if they have the money for it.
Susan Daniels: They have the authority to make that decision, there would be the ones making the decision to arm to add the additional component of work.
Susan Daniels: Now, if you meant the question was how do I handle a stakeholder who wants to you know, change the scope of my project.
Susan Daniels: that's where the safeguards of your your formal change control and having your change request document developed that you just send it to them a whole lecture on how to manage change coming, but your scope can be adjusted.
Susan Daniels: It can be but through formal change.
Susan Daniels: let's see let's, thank you for not adding more questions i'm going to we go back over your method of sending the wps dictionary survey.
Susan Daniels: On basically you use this lie that you have you can use your pen box sixth edition on a wps dictionary it'll tell you what's in it they're also there's an item ization.
Susan Daniels: um you build a questionnaire that talks about what you need to know for scope schedule cost quality procurement stakeholder communications teams resources risks everything it's an extensive questionnaire.
Susan Daniels: You design it usually a word document and you create a standard template email, please find attached the you know the questionnaire to help build out the project plan.
Susan Daniels: The questionnaire relative to your your work package that you're accountable for please complete the questionnaire give him a reasonable period of time and then ask them to send it back.
Susan Daniels: I generally build all of these and put them in draft form, so that everybody gets the questionnaire, at the same time.
Susan Daniels: And it all comes back to me at the same time, and that way, then I can sequester myself for a couple of days.
Susan Daniels: and use all this information to start to build out my first draft of my schedule and my risk identification right my risk register and I just start pulling this information and building out the rest of my plans um.
Susan Daniels: I hope that's helpful ask a follow up question if you need to is there a consolidated flow chart for the components of the project development visual can connections for walk were covered um as in what do I do next, and when do I do it, yes um.
Susan Daniels: If you go into the on pin box sixth edition, you will see our flow diagrams of the different documents and how they are used by different parts of the project, how the web is is leveraged by schedule and budget, you will see how different.
Susan Daniels: deliverables all relate to each other, yes, if you become a member of pmi dot O rg.
Susan Daniels: And you go into standards and guides, you will see a link that will take you to the pen box sixth edition, it might be parked in PM on.
Susan Daniels: The PM standards, plus I heard a rumor that's where it moved to or was going to move to either way you can get to it as a member of pmi looking through that the first two pages of each chapter, are some of the flow charts you may be looking for.
Susan Daniels: Okay let's see.
Susan Daniels: Okay, to clarify sponsors our clients and stakeholders are collaborative TEAM members government standards okay.
Susan Daniels: sponsors are people who have the money to make the project happen Okay, they think of sponsors as spenders okay sponsors, are the ones that are spending the money that they've gotten to have this project happen.
Susan Daniels: stakeholders, of course, all sponsors are stakeholders and all TEAM members are stakeholders stakeholders or individuals agencies or organizations that.
Susan Daniels: Can impact are impacted or perceived they could be you know dis out there on the French proceed they could be impacted by your projects processes.
Susan Daniels: or outcomes so stakeholders are people who might care sponsors are think of stakeholders people with opinions okay and sponsors and people who can spend are authorized spending.
Susan Daniels: um the veto veto mentioned float in relation to sequencing could you just find that again for us on flow is going to be covered, when we get into.
Susan Daniels: Developing the critical path there's a whole video on it so you're ahead of the game appreciate the question but it's going to be answered a little later.
Susan Daniels: Okay.
Susan Daniels: Why do I keep referencing the sixth edition, and not the seventh edition, because I know that's exactly where it's at and the seventh edition on is really doesn't go as deep on each topic and is.
Susan Daniels: The sixth edition is 700 pages, the seventh edition is like 200 plus pages so it's in references things but it doesn't go deep on anything.
Susan Daniels: it's sort of introduces concepts and then you can then go find more about going through the pmi standards and guides and PM standards, plus sort of says.
Susan Daniels: Go look over here, where the sixth edition was the guide to the body of knowledge Okay, so I keep coming back to the six because it's a great place to point a person specifically to.
Susan Daniels: is getting a pmi membership recommended highly recommended within your yes when pursuing your p&p certification.
Susan Daniels: um it's it will provide you so many tools that you would want to have as a practitioner it helps you from reinventing the wheel, it gives you templates it gives you guidelines it gives you.
Susan Daniels: insights articles it's just a wealth of information and being a project management professional with a pmi certification, being a member of that organization it's it just makes sense right um.
Susan Daniels: Okay, what is the test on sixth or seventh both plus additional information.
Susan Daniels: Many other reference documents that's why you're taking this this exam prep class, because we have distilled the key concepts terms and tools and techniques into what you need to know to pass the exam but the exam does cover both the sixth and seventh.
Susan Daniels: Do you need to purchase him back in addition to the learner kit to have the tools needed no, you do not need to purchase any pinball guide it is part of your membership a pmi okay.
Susan Daniels: um Do I need to purchase it to study your the materials that are provided to you through the platform that you're coming in, will be sufficient for you to pass the test okay.
Susan Daniels: it's just said, having these guides and access to these guides are wonderful reference documents to come back to as you're a practitioner.
Susan Daniels: What version of him.
Susan Daniels: What version should I study for the exam if you're choosing to actually study the box, you need to be from you should look at both but I will repeat the materials that are provided to you, through your learning platforms are going to be sufficient for you to pass the test so.
Susan Daniels: um is today ending at six or at eight um it really depends on where you're from but in i'm going to be concluding at 6pm Eastern time you can you know translate that for where you are okay.
Susan Daniels: I have reached the bottom of the hour, it is 130 on still feel free to send me a couple more questions if you want, I will try to capture them and.
Susan Daniels: To the extent that I can I may be able to answer a couple of them when we get back together, but we are officially on lunch break I will see you at 230 Eastern time have a nice lunch break.